esta vez vamos a decir que tenemos tres
vectores tengo a un vector que le voy a
llamar am aquí tengo a mi pectoral ya
este efecturá le voy a sumar déjenme
cambiar de color
le voy a sumar este vector nuevo llamado
ven ok
imagínate que la suma de estos dos me da
de resultado el vector se la suma de
estos dos me da de resultado el vector
se ok ahora lo que quiero que pienses en
este vídeo es si existe alguna forma en
alguno de los escenarios donde se cumpla
esto que la magnitud de este vector se
ok esto sea exactamente igual o que que
la magnitud del vector a déjame cambiar
de color que la magnitud del vector am
ok y a esto le voy a sumar ya esto le
voy a sumar la magnitud de este vector b
la magnitud de este vector
habrá algún escenario donde se cumpla
esto dado que este vector se es lo mismo
que la suma de estos otros dos vectores
o bueno también me gustaría que pensaras
en otro posible escenario en donde se
cumpla que la suma de estos dos vectores
sea el vector ce no forzosamente tienen
que ser los mismos vectores que se
cumplen acá abajo pero que pase lo
siguiente que la magnitud de este vector
se ok sea
mayor sea más grande que la suma de
estos dos es decir que tomarme la
magnitud la magnitud del vector am ok ya
esto a sumarle vamos a cambiar a este a
esto sumarle la magnitud del vector b y
lo que quiero es que pause este vídeo y
que pienses un poco en estas dos
expresiones que tengo aquí la primera
que tenga un vector se que se obtenga de
la suma de estos dos vectores y que se
cumpla que la magnitud de este vector se
sea igual que la magnitud del vector am
más la magnitud del vector mem
sería mi primer escenario y me gustaría
que también pensarás en un escenario
donde se cumpla esto de acá arriba pero
que la magnitud del vector se sea más
grande sea mayor que la magnitud del
pectoral más la magnitud del vector b se
podrán encontrar estos escenarios es
momento de que en pause este vídeo
bien una vez que estoy suponiendo que ya
pausas del vídeo y que seguramente te
sentiste bastante frustrado con este
segundo caso vamos a intentar ver qué es
lo que pasa con estos tres vectores así
que para eso lo primero que se me ocurre
es intentar dibujar dos por aquí
imagínate que aquí me tomo al vector a
am y se ve más o menos así este es mi
vector am
déjame ponerlo así y bueno también
imagínate que por aquí me tomo al vector
b
voy a dibujar por acá a otro vector ok
este va a ser mi vector ven ok vamos a
ponerlo así este le voy a poner el
vector b y qué te parece si yo me fijo
en la suma del vector up con el vector b
bueno pues para esto voy a atrapar a
este ok vamos a tratarlo no primero lo
voy a atrapar algo así ok y lo voy a
copiar lo voy a pegar ok de lujo y este
lo voy a poner justo acá para que
tengamos
aquí el vector a am aquí al vector ven y
ahora me voy a fijar en la suma del
vector a con el vector b y de hecho me
da este
este king es la suma del vector am con
el vector ven y déjame ponerle su
respectiva flecha ahora lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que se formó un
triángulo y en casi todas las
combinaciones posibles se forma un
triángulo cuando nosotros pensamos en el
vector am en el vector b y en el vector
c que es la suma del vector a con el
vector ven ahora noticia de último
momento siempre que nos tomemos estos
tres vectores se va a formar un
triángulo y bueno cuando nosotros
tenemos un triángulo y nos tomamos a uno
de estos lados este nunca va a ser mayor
que la suma de sus otros dos lados y
esto siempre pasa en todos los
triángulos ahora podríamos intentar
buscar la forma de que este vector se
tuviera una longitud más y más y más
grande tú podrías tratar de cambiar un
poco el orden de estos seguir pensando
en este con el vector am y este vector b
lo podremos tratar de mover un poco para
camps para que así se forme un triángulo
con este vector c mucho más grande y se
vería más o menos así
tenemos por aquí déjame ganar este a mi
pectoral electoral se podría ver
exactamente igual sería más o menos así
ok
imagínate que esto es mi lectora no
importa que vector sea y hacia donde
vaya siempre lo podemos tomar
exactamente igual y ahora imagínate que
me tomo a otro vector ver este vector by
le cambiamos la dirección y que vaya más
o menos para acá si va más o menos para
acá estoy moviendo lo hacia la derecha y
entonces se ve que se va a formar otro
triángulo un triángulo mucho más amplio
en el vector c sin embargo va a cumplir
lo mismo date cuenta que aquí tengo
ahora a mi vector c
ok esté aquí sería mi vector c sin
embargo sigue cumpliendo que su longitud
es menor que la suma de la longitud de
los otros dos vectores siempre va a ser
menor excepto en uno de los casos la
única forma en que tenga la misma
longitud la misma magnitud es que se
cumpla que estos dos vectores vayan en
la misma dirección vamos a ver con calma
qué es lo que pasa cuando yo tengo que
el vector am y déjame tomar este color
este de aquí sea mi vector am se ve más
o menos así ok ahora imagínate que mi
vector bm el vector ver tenga la misma
dirección es decir que mi vector p se
vea más o menos así va en la misma
dirección se va a ver más o menos así lo
vamos a mover un poco más hacia la
derecha este ahora es mi vector ven y
date cuenta que en este caso mi sector
se se va a ver de esta manera la suma
del vector a más el vector b se va a ver
de esta manera este de aquí sería muy
vector sem es decir va a ser un vector
que tenga la longitud exactamente igual
que la suma de las dos longitudes de
estos dos vectores y ese va a ser el
caso en el que se cumpla esta igualdad
que tengo aquí esta igualdad que tengo
aquí se cumple solamente en este caso
que tengo justo aquí y es el valor más
grande que podría tomar este efecto
cuando se cumpla que estos dos vectores
este de aquí y este dakar tengan la
misma la misma dirección dirección de
dirección y es éste el único caso en
donde este vector se va a tomar la
magnitud más grande que pueda tomar y la
magnitud más grande que pueda tomar es
exactamente igual que la magnitud del
vector am más la magnitud del vector b
que es justo este caso de acá este caso
de acá abajo es imposible no hay forma
de que se cumpla esta desigualdad que
tenemos aquí abajo y bueno tienen mucha
lógica porque nunca vas a poder tener un
lado de un triángulo más grande que la
suma de los otros dos lados justo por lo
que acabamos de ver y bueno seguramente
también te vas a preguntar qué es lo que
pasa con el último caso qué es lo que
pasa cuando nosotros tenemos en que la
magnitud en que la magnitud de la suma
es decir la magnitud de c
o sea menor o igual que la suma de las
magnitudes así que déjame ponerlo así y
aquí tengo la magnitud de este vector a
ok ya estoy am le voy a sumar a con este
color
le voy a sumar la magnitud de este
vector b es decir lo que quiero fijarme
es cuando se cumple este caso que la
magnitud de la suma de los dos vectores
sea menor que la suma de las magnitudes
y bueno es que esto ya sabemos cuando se
cumple se cumple cuando los dos vectores
no tengan la misma dirección este es el
caso más común cuando los dos vectores
no tengan la misma dirección entonces se
va a cumplir esta desigualdad que
tenemos aquí así que si por ejemplo
ahora tomamos dos vectores se me ocurre
en este de aquí a este vector de aquí
ok déjame decir que este es un vector
dibujando aquí una pequeña flecha a este
vector
le voy a sumar otro vector y se me
ocurre tomarme
este de aquí a este le voy a sumar este
de aquí ok este también es otro vector y
bueno vamos a ponerle algunas a alguna
par de magnitudes así que voy a suponer
que este tiene una longitud de 3 una
magnitud de 3 y este tiene una magnitud
de org
así que si yo me tomo la suma de estos
dos y bueno para eso aunque te parece si
agarro a este de aquí y lo voy a atrapar
ok y lo voy a cortar y ahora lo voy a
pegar por aquí ok vamos a ponerlo justo
aquí entonces tú ya sabes que como no
tienen la misma dirección y eso se nota
claramente entonces estamos en el caso
de aquí abajo es decir que el vector que
nos resulte el vector que nos resulte la
suma va a tener una magnitud menor que
la suma de estas dos magnitudes así que
pongámoslo si yo me tomo aquí un nuevo
color se me ocurre este de aquí y me
fijo ahora en este vector que tengo
justo aquí este vector va a ser
por suma de estos dos entonces las vemos
de una manera muy clara que la magnitud
la magnitud de este vector ante este que
tengo aquí va a ser menor que la suma de
estos 28 más 3 es 11 y bueno también
podemos asegurar que la única forma en
que su magnitud sea exactamente igual y
que por cierto va a ser el valor máximo
sea exactamente igual que la suma de
estas dos magnitudes de estos otros dos
vectores es en el caso de que estos dos
vectores tengan la misma dirección que
estos dos vectores tengan la misma
dirección